what's the difference between a
capitalist and a socialist when it comes
down to their philosophy speaking
publicly what is the difference between
a capitalist and a socialist when it
comes down to telling the world publicly
what's the difference
the socialist says i'll do everything
for you the capital that says no thank
you i'll do it myself the capitalist is
very comfortable telling the world he's
a capitalist the socialist keeps it a
secret until he has enough control to
say all along i was about socialism
there's a video that a guy sent me
yesterday i'm going to send to you tyler
to play this of maxine waters did you
see that video or no no so this is from
2008 when the marquee crash takes place
which by the way you're going to see
this
happening in america today tyler i'm
texting it to you to put it up just show
the text of what i just sent you
so oh wait there's a hearing
and maxine waters is talking to the ceo
of shell
and the ceo of shell is saying look if
you keep doing what you're doing
five dollar gas prices are going to be a
thing of the past this is when oh wait
14 years ago look at maxine waters
response just put the audio
uh uh yeah put the audio up and just
play it from the beginning watch this
folks to the american people because of
the inaction of the united states
congress ever increasing prices unless
the demand comes down and the five
dollars will look like a very low price
in the years to come if we are
prohibited from finding new reserves new
opportunities to increase supplies and
guess what this liberal would be all
about this liberal will be all about
socializing uh um
would be about
the ladies
taking over
and the government running all of your
companies
to the american people did you see she
couldn't even
so all i'm saying to you is folks
speculation let's speculate okay that's
i can speculate you don't have to
speculate let me do the speculation you
stick to the red-headed i'm going to
stick with speculation you ready here's
some speculation okay
if
there was a strategy
with oil prices
to nationalize it what would you do
first first
you create policies like shutting down
the what the keystone
pipeline that we can control gas prices
shut them down first day one which they
did
two you actually allow gas prices to
increase to hurt who low and middle
income families three you blame who
shell
exxon mobil everybody four you come in
you say what this is why oil should be
something that's nationalized and
managed by who the government if that's
your strategy that's the proper
four-step sequence to nationalize oil
okay and folks you do not want
that industry to be nationalized as much
as you know they're thinking we're gonna
go green we did a video on ev versus uh
uh gas
the the the price paid to go 100 ev
it's going to be on the backs of a lot
of workers in
uh what is that one place in africa the
congo democratic congo that's got what
60 of the cobalt or some 64 percent of
the world's cobalt that china bought the
land to this place yeah and all these
people that are working this is not
going to be an overnight thing you use
oil
more than you think we do but the
marketing and the way the story is
telling being told it's different so
socialize you just saw maxine waters
from california she tried to hold the
back couldn't do it slipped up she
couldn't do it in no way it slipped up
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]